Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of
the Decent. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops
. And today I'm joined by Doctor Claudio 10.
He is a tenured research group leader in the Department
of Early Prehistory and Quaternary Ecology at the University of
Tubingen. This is our second interview. I'm leaving
the link to our first one in the description box
. Uh And today we're going to talk basically about
the differences between ape culture and human culture. So
, Doctor 10 Year, welcome back to the show
. It's always a pleasure to talk to you.
It's a great pleasure to talk to you and thank
you very much for having me a second time.
Thanks, great. So OK, let's perhaps start
with some basics here. Uh How would you define
ape culture? What is ape culture? Right?
Yeah. Well, uh ape culture would be cultures
um shown by apes. But when we talk about
culture generally, and this is uh always news for
newcomers to the field. At first, it turns
out that culture is quite a slippery fish. It's
quite difficult to uh measure it to, to really
get hold of uh culture generally, not just in
apes anywhere. And um to see why that is
, you know, we can imagine that we can
measure genes, you know, the existence of genes
. Anyway, um what to make with this data
is a different matter. But we can measure them
, you know, we can find them same for
environment. You know, we can measure the temperature
somewhere, we can measure the humidity, uh someplace
and so on. But with culture, it is
difficult, it continues to be difficult to really measure
our culture. Culture is something that happens out in
the world sometimes stays out in the world such as
cultural artifacts and so on. But it is also
something that is very much in minds in brains.
And we don't have very good means to get to
these brains, you know, uh it's not something
that I personally do, for example. So the
general approach had been then in the past, in
order to try to pinpoint culture is to take away
the signal and the factors from other um uh areas
. So, for example, to try to find
, if you control for, if you measure and
, and um adjust for genetic differences, and if
you measure and control for environmental differences between populations,
if you do both of these things, the idea
is that what is left over, if there is
some difference, still left over between these populations,
that you can call that difference um cut. So
it's an approach that the philosophers call an X Negativo
approach. It's basically defining uh something by uh the
absence of all the other things. Um And that
is what, what culture has been uh come to
be seen. And also in the apes, I
can talk more later, maybe about this, but
population differences between apes that are not very obviously linked
to genetic differences and um environmental differences, that's what
people call ape culture. Uh And so, uh
I would imagine that we can study ape culture through
different means. So I guess that perhaps some aspects
of it could be studied in the lab, but
we can also study ape culture in the wild.
So, um uh what do we know about wild
ape culture? And is it similar or different to
human culture? Yes. So wild ape culture is
a prototypical case of ape culture. Wild ape culture
is what most people focus on. Really when you
, when you open up your TV channel and you
see David Attenborough come up and talk about, I
don't know chimpanzee nut cracking or something and so on
. And then they would invariably talk about some culture
there. That's what they are ultimately uh on about
, they talk about these dissimilarities between populations and they
call that um culture. And again, uh when
, when you ask about the similarities, now,
now we get into the topic of what we are
talking about today. Um The similarities uh there is
some similarity in the sense that indeed we also see
in humans, population differences, right, the way
that I eat uh rice might be different to how
some other people and some other populations eat rice.
Right? So there are some differences and these differences
can indeed be meaningfully linked to some cultural processes.
So on that level, on the surface level,
we are dealing with a similar phenomenon, we are
dealing with population differences. And by the way,
if somebody were to say this is a cultural difference
, you know, on this very rough level,
just to talk about culture per se, I have
no problem with that. Um uh If you know
, if the method of exclusion, that's this method
to exclude genetic and environmental differences. If, if
it had been applied correctly, uh then, you
know, I have no problem with that. But
this does not mean that the culture specifics underlying these
cases are or must be the same. And this
is basically where I have the biggest difficulties always in
getting our main point across the main point from my
research group is to say they, that is not
to say that apes don't have culture. This is
a point that is very frequently misconstruct. The point
is not to say that apes don't have culture.
The point is to say Ape apes have culture,
but that culture might be very different from the culture
of humans. That's essentially our main point here.
Um Yeah, but, but, but, but
the rest of the devil is in the details and
so on. Uh But I'm sure we're gonna get
to this. Yeah. But do you think that
when studying a culture, uh we have to be
careful about, uh what would probably be some of
the differences that arise between, for example, studying
it uh when the animals are uh captive versus uh
in the wild? Um Well, there are different
opinions on that. Uh The, the opinion,
the main opinion is, I guess for most people
out in the world, many, most people are
very interested in apes generally and they are somehow very
interested in ape culture generally. But when they are
interested in these things, they are usually interested most
in the wild ape cultural case. However, you
can also do similar methods, you can apply them
across different populations of captive apes, for example.
And then you can find also some population differences between
these captive populations that suggests, it suggests that perhaps
we are dealing here with similar phenomenon, meaning that
the similar phenomenon might be underlain by very similar mechanisms
as well. But here is where then some people
um disagree. Some people would then say there is
a, there is a big difference between wild apes
and captive apes. And uh that is, I
mean, theoretically speaking, you know, that could
well be. Um but then you look at the
arguments and the there is already a problem, the
arguments that people then bring are go are pointing to
completely the opposite patterns. So I'm not explaining this
very well. People make different claims with regard to
this difference, wildly different claims. So some people
essentially claim I, I have to turn this down
a little bit here because we don't have much time
. Um So I'm painting with a very broad brush
here. Some people would then say that um captive
apes are stupid. Again, I'm painting with a
broad brush. Uh So then they would say the
captive apes, they, they can't do very much
and so on the wild apes, they can do
many more things and they are really clever ones and
so on. So these people would then essentially claim
that captivity impoverishes the cognition, um intelligence if you
so on, you know, of these things.
But then you look and some other people say the
exact opposite. They say actually, you know,
there is a thing they call it a captivity effect
doesn't matter what it's called now. And they say
, oh actually, it turns out that the captive
ones, they are the ones that are showing improved
cognition. So there is a huge problem here.
And um logically speaking, uh unless you finesse it
down into more details, logically speaking, on this
level, one side must be wrong, right?
It cannot be both correct that they are impoverished and
improved in, in their cognition. So that's already
shown you um part of the divide that we have
in the field where people talk about different things without
even agreeing on the basics, even agreeing, they
can't even agree on the overall patterns as it were
. But if you can't agree on this overall patterns
, and it will be very difficult also to frankly
answer once and for all the questions that you ask
me, it's a good question. You know,
is there a difference between the culture of the captive
apes and the word? And there currently it depends
who you ask. Those people who say that uh
the the uh captive apes are impoverished, they will
give you a different answer than those who say uh
you know, that the captive apes are improved in
their cognition or enhanced in their cognition. I personally
think that the difference between wild apes and captive apes
doesn't go as extreme in one direction or the other
as some of these scams have been made, right
? Uh I think also if you, if you
think about it for a second, the fact that
that can be people who, who promote the idea
that, you know, the the difference is like
this, you know, and the others promote the
exact opposite uh idea. Well, maybe what really
is happening is that the, the real difference is
not all that great. And indeed, um unless
we talk about incarcerated apes and so on so forth
, we, we might do so later. Um
Unless you talk about this, the difference is not
that great. Uh And so my answer then would
be quite similar. My answer would be to say
, captive apes are also able to um have an
ape culture just like wild apes do. It's just
that most people focus on white ape culture. That
would be my my personal short answer to that question
. But I mean, I've also asked you about
that because sometimes when we talk about studies that are
done in uh not only with animals but also with
uh humans in the lab, uh There are people
uh that bring to the table criticisms regarding for example
, ecological validity, right? Of those studies.
But I mean, perhaps I'm saying something that is
completely wrong and if so please correct me. But
uh I mean, I I if um couldn't we
treat, let's say captive animals or animals studied in
the lab as uh I mean, those artificial settings
as a different ecology. I mean, would that
make sense? It would, it would absolutely make
sense. You know, we can even go into
an evil route. You could, you could and
people have done that. Unfortunately, in the past
, you can take um single chimpanzees, right?
So you it's a social animal and you better treat
them as social animals and you keep them as social
animals but, but people have taken them and put
them in single cages and that's not only is that
super cruel, we don't need to talk about that
. Everybody would agree that that's a cool thing to
do but that kind of thing, that kind of
thing I am convinced that that does deprive these apes
and it leads to impoverished cognition. So how,
how can we expand from this uh case? Right
, we can expand from it in, in the
following way, I think we can ask the the
more sensible question and the question that can be measured
like how similar to the wild do we need to
create conditions in order to make these cases ecologically comparable
? This is very important because when we do that
, we see that there is not one type of
ecology for chimpanzees. Let's talk about chimpanzees. Generally
, we can talk about all the A I DS
but chimpanzees are the typical case to talk about.
So when we look at chimpanzees across, you know
, Africa, uh we see that they live too
in very widely different situations in different environments, you
know, but also in different sizes of populations.
That is simply the case, right? Um So
some live in small populations actually, you know,
this is there is also an interference with human observation
there, but let's not go in in that direction
. Um And some live in very big uh uh
environments um in big groups and they live in this
different environments too. So what we can glean from
that is the following, we can glean from that
. And, and we can also imagine that in
the past in the environment of evolutionary adapted this of
, of uh chimpanzees and so on. In the
past, there were very likely more variability in their
living conditions. So actually many different environments, social
environments and physical environments, many different environments are compatible
within chimpanzee life, which means that this is good
news as it were for those captive workers. Because
now it's not altogether immediately clear that if you have
a good zoo that provide the aids with uh big
enclosure, say that keep them in uh social settings
, the chimpanzees, especially in social settings, right
? It's not immediately obvious and it's not an immediate
, you know, Trump card against captive work to
say that there are some differences between this situation and
the wild situations. You know, you can always
find the differences. Yes. But the question is
, how much do they matter? And if you
frame it like that, I think it's easy to
see that the answer will depend, right? I
would, I would say uh some zoos are more
ecologically relevant or similar to the range of environments that
uh wild apes have, right? Some are less
, you know, yes, in an ideal world
, you, you take that into account, but
that's why we always report also where we run our
studies. So later meta reviews and so on can
look out for these things. But as I said
earlier, when we actually look, the differences don't
seem to be all that great. Again, if
people have widely different opinions on that. Probably the
truth is somewhere in the middle, which in this
case means they are not altogether incomparable. Yes.
So, uh going back to the wild apes specifically
earlier, I asked you, uh if their culture
is similar or different to humans when it comes to
the differences, do we know exactly what they are
in what ways wild health culture is different from the
human culture? Um Well, many people, when
you ask them, many people would point immediately to
language and they would say humans have language and AIDS
, don't that's what many people would say to a
large degree. I think it's true. Then again
, when, when, when you look more closely
, well, what is language? Language is a
form of communication, right? OK. Do apes
have communication? Surely they have communication, right?
They even have a communication on different channels, you
know, they can uh use gestures, they can
use sounds, you know, so it's not that
there is a complete lack of complexity, say in
their, in their communication, right? And then
you get into essentially linguistics, lin linguistic debates which
are always tough to follow, let's say, right
? Uh They are more for the specialists. And
so let me just summarize what I think most linguists
would say. They would say while that is true
that they have this communication, et cetera, et
cetera. There are some big differences still and what
you always find every year when you, when you
look at this literature, you know, the the
the aid researchers, they, they chip away every
year a little bit, you know, they chip
away at these differences, right? But the chips
that they remove are usually not very, very large
. So the the the overall picture is that a
communication does, I think that it is fair to
say does get closer to human language over time.
But the steps don't seem to be as big as
they would ever reach a complete overlap. Let me
put it this way, right? I'm not an
ape language researcher. Let me, let me,
let me say it like that. But that is
my interpretation from all of this. But in my
own approach, I try to go one step deeper
. I take the following as um as granted,
one major assumption of my, my work is also
and I take this from the linguists. Um they
describe language in all kinds of ways and some specifics
of languages also that we learn from each other,
the words or in gestural language, you know,
in sign language that the specific gestures from each other
, right? The fact that we speak English together
, right? Uh I think none of us as
a as a native speaker, right? That is
because we learned these things from others and also even
our native languages, we learned these things from others
, right? We learned these words from others.
But then what are words in a in a way
um words are a specific type of information. Um
It's in the vocal domain, let's stick with the
vocal domain now. And it's sequences of certain pronunciations
and so on that you really have to learn as
this all sequences a slow. And in my lab
, we, we call this and other cases,
we call that, know how, know how to
pronounce a word, know how to pronounce the word
uh printer, know how to pronounce the word word
water bottle. You know, that, that kind
of thing it is about, know how and,
and I know uh you know, I've, I've
moved away quite a bit from your original question.
I haven't forgotten the question was what is the difference
between ape and human culture? Right? OK.
So let's take for granted that language is still the
big difference maker. But now we see that in
order to get language, you need several factors as
the linguist, they've got whole list. But one
of these factors that is necessary is that you need
to be able to copy arbitrary strings, arbitrary,
know how. And another way of saying that is
you need to copy, know how that you yourself
will not have come up with uh any time in
your life unless you had copied it from others.
So nobody wakes up in the morning without ever having
had contact with uh Mandarin and speaks Mandarin. You
know that that is just not the case. We
all know this, but the the background to that
is that it consists among other things of know how
pronouncing all these words um that we could not just
produce our own. So our lab, we call
that and I know it's a bit of a mouthful
, right? We call that super individual, know
how s above individual beyond the individual. No,
is the term. The whole idea goes back to
classical uh research and cultural evolution. The whole idea
goes back to Boyd and Richardson who pointed out that
, you know, a special type of culture,
cumulative culture, I would like to add cumulative culture
of know how produces, you know, ways of
doing things and so on. Um that nobody on
their own could develop uh from scratch anymore. So
we just, you know, we just gave this
a label. Uh We, we specified a little
bit more, we said it's about know how and
we specified uh you know, the whole idea in
the extrovert super individual. So the difference then,
and this is the high positive, but it's really
very well supported by now, the difference is that
humans have recounted them roughly and we found billions,
billions of cases of super individual know-how across the whole
planet, across all humans, billions. And then
in the case of the apes, you know,
do they have super individual? Know how, I
mean, the interview is continuing, we can talk
more about that. But let me give you a
very rough answer. And the answer is if,
if apes have, I should specify un incarcerated,
untrained apes, if they have super individual know how
they have it in very rare cases. So a
couple of cases, maybe a handful of cases,
but maybe also they have none and these handful of
cases may be illusions. Um But then we have
the answer in focus. Now the answer is essentially
uh human life would be widely different. What is
inconceivable in its current form. If we were to
take all these super individual know how away everything would
come to a grinding halt. We wouldn't have computers
, we wouldn't have language, we wouldn't have any
of these things, you know, you and I
, we wouldn't uh be able to talk to each
other, you and I, we wouldn't have names
, you know. So that is what, what
my approach has been for for many years now.
Um to say that the difference is that we humans
, we are um we, we are able to
copy, know how, even if there's no how
it is super individual and we indeed do. And
we have created all of this around us in this
way. OK. So perhaps I could save this
question for later. But since you brought it already
to the table, let's censor it now. So
uh you mentioned there the question, I mean,
if other apes have some, some form of super
individual know how uh I mean, what are examples
of that. And I mean, what are examples
of that where some people might claim that they in
fact have that? Yes. So um here is
it is an interesting approach. If you do the
data approach, where you actually look systematically, what
are these cases, you find actually a different answer
than when you ask people like that at a conference
. For example, when II I do this kind
of thing as well, I ask around, you
know, I, I talk to people. So
when I explain what I'm after and I explain,
you know, I'm I'm after know how not know
where food is, not know what food is.
You know, this thing, whether it's that thing
, we all know that apes can learn socially also
about these things. When I say no, no
, we are talking about know how more specifically not
know how that they can do on their own,
what my lab calls latent solutions. It doesn't matter
what we call that, you know, let's stick
with this. Know how. So we are not
talking about this latent know-how, we are talking about
super individual. When I explain all that, they
give me answers such as OK. But then for
example, they would say, for example, Chimpanzee
nut cracking would be uh one of these cases,
right? Chimpanzee nut cracking. Um I don't need
to explain, they use uh some hammers to crack
, open some nuts, you know, very cool
behavior. Nobody denies that. But it's a question
is that a good idea, you know, to
call that super individual, know how, in fact
, um this is so convincing to most people per
se per se without looking at the data that uh
the United Nations have now uh started to protect Chimpanzee
nutcracker. The United Nations protect Chimpanzee nut cracking.
The whole idea there is that this is they don't
use these terms. But the whole idea is that
this is so human like that, this is super
individual. Know how that this is not know how
that the apes would ever show unless they had developed
this culture around it. That's the idea, right
? And again, nobody is saying that this is
a stupid idea. You know, it's not a
stupid idea. It's just a matter of does it
actually fit the data? And so what we have
done is we have given um uh orangutans in two
different zoos orangutans untrained. So they were not trained
to correct nuts, un incarcerated, you know,
so they were not, their cognition wasn't changed by
human interaction. Maybe that's the shortest way I can
describe this, you know, they were left on
their own and nobody showed them how to correct these
nuts, right? We asked the keepers, they
promised us, you know that nobody showed them how
to correct these nuts, right. Well, they
crack nuts, they use an animals and they crack
nuts spontaneously, right? So orangutans don't even crack
nuts in the wild. This would have been maybe
the last remaining uh rescue hypotheses for the United Nations
. Say when they say, oh, maybe they
, they learned it somehow we, because eventually,
if you go back long enough in time, eventually
some orangutans had to come from the wild, maybe
they brought this knowledge along. No, you know
, orangutans don't crack nuts in the wild, not
that we know of anyway. And so we have
basically um uh an ape species very relevant because it's
an ape species, you know, they are all
very closely related to each other and to us um
who didn't bring this knowledge from, there's no help
from the world who wasn't trained to show this knowledge
, who wasn't, you know, cognitively, um
super enhanced by, by human incarceration. And we
didn't show them how to do these things and yet
they take hammers and they crack nuts, right?
So p definition is this is not super individual.
Nohow, by definition, it shows that the individuals
could come up with this know-how. So this latent
know-how, it's know how that they can come up
with on their own. So exactly, unlike the
example that I said earlier when I said nobody wakes
up in the morning and just be able to speak
Mandarin or, or Portuguese or, or whatever,
you know, that doesn't happen. But in a
is it does happen that, you know, they
, they encounter the situation and as long as they
are motivated. It's very important, motivated to actually
eat these nuts. We, we tried this with
chimpanzees as well and they were not motivated to eat
the nuts. And of course, you can't study
it. But you know, if they are motivated
, then um apparently they can do it, you
know, so the answer then that people give you
what is super individual, know how in the apes
you can then go and you test it in these
ways. And we have done many, many such
tests. And the overwhelming result from all these tests
is that people make these claims, right? And
the claim, nobody you know is fine to make
this claim. But then you test it and we
showed many of these papers are still yet to be
published. You know, uh we show that these
kind of know how develop spontaneously in individuals. And
therefore it does not require the special human skill,
it does not require the skill to copy. This
is very important, the skill to copy super individual
know how instead all they need is uh being able
to trigger each other's latent, know how they do
that. But that's a different thing, right?
I can this is a bad example because it's a
hard wire behavior, but I can trigger you to
yawn, you don't have to copy the know how
of the yawn from me, right? Just to
give you an example that it happens in humans too
, but it's very rare in the human case,
right? We don't, that's not usually the way
that we work that we learn from each other.
Right? But it is a typical way that the
apes learn from each other. And, you know
, yes, they, they, you have to
have some social learning in the apes and it's clearly
is there otherwise they wouldn't have culture. Right.
So, um if you bring it all together apes
have culture, yes, but their culture is different
in the sense that they don't copy super individual,
know how, which prevents logically, which prevents the
cultural evolution of this. Know how, because if
the apes, even if some ape comes up with
a super great uh know how on their own.
Let's imagine an ape genius uh scenario. Let's just
imagine this, this a genius comes up with a
super great super individual or maybe a techni technological way
to crack nuts like 100 in an hour, you
know, let's, you know, we humans do
this kind of thing. So why not? You
know, so um this a genius comes up with
that, but if the other apes are unable to
copy super individual, know how they are not in
this example, they would not be geniuses. Well
, the predictable outcome would be that this invention would
die with its maker. You know, all the
others would do the kind of things that they are
able to do on their own again, a long
answer. But, but that is maybe the shortest
I can do for this question. Great. So
uh before we move on to another topic, I
mean, the questions I have asked you up till
now that were mostly related to wild ape culture and
how similar or different it is to human culture.
I mean, of course, uh intellectually the I
guess these questions are very interesting but from the perspective
of someone who's trying to study and understand the culture
, cultural evolution, why should we bother with these
questions? I mean, why, why does it
matter if wild ape culture is similar or different to
human culture and if similar or different in what way
, specifically, why should we bother with this question
? Um So generally speaking, I think what we
are doing in all these cases is we are not
, we're not producing anything, you know, this
is not, you know, this is not feeding
humans on the planet or the answer to this question
, right? So it's essential basic science, essentially
basic science, but that we are doing here,
we're just trying to understand systems. That's, that's
what we do. And within that, I think
we have got a couple of different approaches. I
am, I am a biologist by training originally.
Now, I'm also an archaeologist, but I am
originally a biologist. And so for me, it's
just of general interest to find out how apes behave
and uh what ape culture is where it comes from
and, and so on and to describe it,
you know, so that's generally interesting, but there
are a couple of other things that are more broadly
interesting. Um So for example, to, to
be able to talk about animal culture, generally,
we would need to study as many animal species as
possible. Some people now even claim that plants have
some social learning. So we would have to include
them in some general very general cultural category. So
apes then would be one part of this general puzzle
that we should study everything that we can in an
ideal world. But in addition to that, um
we can use this kind of knowledge, this hard
gain knowledge in order to try to understand um cultural
settings generally and cultural evolution generally and specifically for humans
. And here is where the apes of course play
very um large role. They play a large role
because they are our closest living relatives. And so
in addition to being of interest in and of themselves
, they are highly, potentially highly uh phylogenetic informative
. Uh if we understand ape culture, it gives
us a handle to have a likelihood, understanding a
likelihood, understanding of uh the last common ancestor with
apes. So if we find some patterns that are
shared among all living apes today, chances are good
. Chances are good is the implication that the last
common ancestor also shared in. It's not the perfect
uh uh data set, right. Ideally, we
would have to have hundreds of living ape species that
would be much better for this kind of influence.
But it's the best that we have, you know
, and, and so we should use it and
then we can infer with a certain likelihood what the
last common ancestor ancestors culture was like. And we
can then build from that. And that is,
that is my other area of research. But I
think we talked about that last time to a high
uh degree. So I would be refer listeners interested
in that what we are homing in our own past
ancestors, cultures like and so on that we,
that we debated last time. So uh people could
maybe listen to that then. Yes, of course
. And as I said, at the beginning,
I'm linking to our first interview in the description of
this one. And by the way, just to
clarify when you mentioned that a certain point there,
our last common ancestor with apes. Are you referring
specifically to the last common ancestor? We have,
we have with chimpanzees or going all the way back
to the one from which uh orangutans and gorillas also
wrenched. I would, I would say the typical
way that people talk about it, the last common
ancestor and they say it just like that and it's
the last common ancestor we have together with the chimpanzees
and the bonobos, right? Um But my lab
has also been, again, I would refer to
the last interview we did has also looked at all
the other apes and so on so forth. We
should really, ideally, we should look at all
primates. Uh But uh you know, that's hard
to do. It's, it's very difficult to get
all the data for the apes. So another question
, then there's this similarity hypothesis that people apply to
the kinds of questions we've been talking about here.
So what is the similarity hypothesis? And what are
the types of claims that people have proposed in favor
of it? I think if you ask around us
the conferences, the the the the things that convinced
most people sometime in their Androgyny, you know,
um many are convinced this is how I started too
. I was convinced by the similarity of hypothesis in
the beginning too. And then the data changed my
mind, my own data uh changed my mind but
also other people's data. Um So many people arrived
there because they had heard this in school that all
primates of human like culture, sometimes this was just
implicit by the teachers, you know, and then
people just pick it up in this way. Sometimes
it was said explicitly, I've asked some people a
little bit about that, but many also arrived because
in public uh common media, imagine Attenborough and so
on. But of course, other people in wildlife
documentaries and so on, the typical way that they
describe these things is that they say, yeah,
yeah, this is all exactly like in the human
case. And then of course, um, it
looks also, I have to admit it looks at
first it looks quite humanlike. Right. Um,
so why would people based on that, why would
they come away watching these things and hearing these things
? Why would they come away with a skeptical mindset
? Right. There's absolutely no reason for that.
But, and, and, and that's why I
arrived at the scene, you know, uh like
that, I, I believed, you know,
that apes would have human like culture. Um So
, you know, if you look at that just
superficially, there is something already wrong with this uh
approach because when you look even superficially at ape life
and then human life even cross culturally, you do
see differences, right? So there is a problem
if you think about it like that, if you
begin to actually compare with the human case, but
let's not, let's not go in this direction right
now, a different direction is to basically say what
we, the the main convincing things are that people
see videos say of uh mother chimpanzee doing some things
and then often cut videos, you know, sometimes
not even the same individual, but it can be
the same individual uh later on these youngsters doing similar
things, all right. Uh So that's very convincing
to people, then I always point out yes.
But uh that is also the explanation that people had
in the past for um how birds learn to make
their nests, they believe was that they always have
to learn how to make their nest, how notice
how, you know, they learn what material where
this material is for sure. But the how,
that's the question and uh the crucial uh studies there
were done uh many years ago, Colas and Colas
, for example, did a study on river bird
nest making weaver birds are fantastic because they super fantastic
. N you know, super great design, seemingly
very complicated and so on. So what they did
is they took an egg, the beauty with birds
is that you can take them as an egg.
They can't have seen anything, right? And then
they raised these eggs outside of the view of any
nests, let alone nest making and then they ate
it, you know, and uh these river birds
completely naive to nest and nest making, they made
the species typical nest and then, you know,
people immediately get it, you know, they say
, yeah, the, the logic is super clear
here. We may have assumed that the birds have
to copy how to make the nests. But these
kind of studies conclusively prove that they don't. Hm
. And then I say, ok, now we
talked about uh birds somehow, you know, birds
are much less emotional and the logic is much clearer
to see, you know, let's go to this
, unfortunately, very emotional case of the apes.
And what if I were to tell you that,
you know, you see mother chimpanzee do something,
uh baby chimpanzee do something if we now remove this
knowledge, right? And they still do it.
And I, I told you about this one example
in the orangutan case already, you know, they
didn't have to see these kind of things. It's
logically, it's the same structure in the river bird
case as in the orangutan nut cracking case, if
they can do these things on their own, it
proves that the assumption that they have to copy these
things was wrong, right? Um So that's,
that's essentially one aspect. But there are, there
are two more I think. Um another is that
people point to uh to super rare behaviors. Uh
And they say, look, you know, this
is similar to the human case. We've got this
super rare behaviors only occurs here only occurs here in
this particular population of say chimpanzees. And again,
the intuition, we can, we can long discuss
why that is the case. But I don't need
to because people have this intuition already. So I
don't need to explain why that is actually not a
bad argument per se. Um But then we tested
that. So um I A Motes Rodrigo, my
, my phd student at the time and I,
we tested that and we looked at all these claims
where people have said this kind of know how only
exists in this one population of one specific um species
of apes and we asked around and we look for
the literature that came later. Uh if that is
actually the case and we found that in 99% of
cases that was not the case or 98% you know
, was not the case. Instead these things did
repeat someplace else. They, they, they,
that shows that this intuition, even though it was
not a bad intuition, you know, it was
actually not correct in, in the vast majority of
cases, a know how repeats across different things.
It pops up time and again. And then you
have to explain why does it pop up time and
again. And our approach is to say, well
, because it is latently present anyway, right?
And it requires certain conditions, um motivational issues,
environmental conditions, et cetera, et cetera, tiny
details to then create different patches of these cultures everywhere
. That's cultural. Let's let's be very clear about
this, but it's different cultural from the human case
because we culturally evolve our know how on top of
this, you know, very different uh approach.
Oh yeah. And uh and lastly, I think
what many people are also convinced of is when they
see, for example, let's say uh in a
Hollywood movie these days, luckily Hollywood does a lot
of CG I for apes and so on. But
in the past, they would have a trained ape
and that ape would act say very human like,
right? And then they, this the number of
people who came to this belief because of these kind
of images goes down, I think, but they
still exist. And so they basically then say,
uh look, I've seen apes act like humans.
What are you, what are you talking about?
Claudio, I've seen apes look like humans and act
like humans. So they must have copied it from
humans. And that is not true. We can
, we can make a bear ride a motorcycle in
circles. It's not that I would do this,
but we can. But that doesn't mean that why
natural bears ride motorcycles, right? So we have
to keep separate, trained behavior and going even further
, we have to keep separate and incarcerated apes that
you know, that are very special, incarcerated apes
are a special case. They are again irrelevant for
the aggression of wild ape cultures. But it's much
harder to see why they are irrelevant for this case
. But uh why should we study un inculturated and
untrained apes? What kind of information can we get
from them? So the again, the trained,
the trained apes, if we, if we were
to train a dog, say, uh if we
were to train a dog to not like meat,
let's just make it very simple. It's not about
know how this is about, know what, know
what to eat, but it doesn't matter for now
, then it's very easy to see that this is
not representative anymore for wolves. Why would wolves not
like me, right. So if you were to
take, of course, dogs are uh domesticated animals
, we can use a non-domestic animal with a similar
logic. It's easy enough to do. So let's
just stick with the dogs. Um So if we
were to make them train them not to do something
, we can do that, right? Uh But
that is not um relevant for extrapolating what wild animals
would be doing. This is just one example,
but they, the one generalizes, we can train
animals generally via clicker training. I've done this myself
, you know, uh all kinds of race.
Um We can do that and they perform things including
even if we want to know how we can make
a dog done salsa, right? Uh We can
do, we can install, know how in them
that would never come about in wild animals. That
means that we need to exclude all of these cases
where we train the, know how into these animals
. Because the question is not, is decidedly not
, can for example, an ape, can an
ape, can an ape show some human know how
that question is a different question, that question we
can answer yes because for example, we can train
them to our question here is different. Our question
is can a spontaneously copy super individual nohow, copy
and spontaneous, you know, these, these are
the two things that we have to have in place
because if they are not spontaneous. Um And if
it's not copying, then this is not what we
are really after. You know, that's, that's
what we are after here. Oh, yeah.
And with the incarceration, the incarceration is a little
bit complicated. So bear with me a little bit
. Ok. Um There are two general, two
general approaches to explaining why we humans have special social
learning abilities. So just so, you know,
yes, I'm, my research group is a little
bit special that we talk about, know how copying
supervision, know how copying. So we specify it
like that. But we are by no means alone
in saying that humans have some special social learning abilities
. Others focus focus much more detailed on imitation and
so on. We think this is too, too
focused, you know, but it doesn't matter.
So we are not the only ones that say humans
have got special social learning abilities, good. Keep
that in mind. So now when we say there
was a whole class of social learning American that's special
. Let's even not say what they are. Then
there are two general approaches to this, how we
humans got to have these special social learning. One
approach is to say they are adaptations, they are
natural adaptations. We have them in our genes essentially
. Again, I'm painting with a very broad product
. These people will then say, well, we
are born with these skills or we are born um
in a way that makes us have these skills very
, very, very likely, you know, OK
, again, broad brush, let's not go into
detail uh here. But there was this other approach
where people say yes, genes play a little bit
of a role, but they play only a small
role and they play an enabling role. They pro
provide a small platform on which we build these skills
and the skills themselves, these special skills, they
are built into us socially. They are built into
us by culture itself. Very unintrusive idea. Basically
what these people say at the forefront of this old
movement right now is uh Cecilia Hayes. What these
people are saying is we culturally learn how to culturally
learn. OK. So why am I, why
am I mentioning this? You will know this anyway
, but I'm mentioning this because if that is true
, let's just assume for this moment that this is
true. This is the correct way. Let's just
assume then humans themselves learn these things culturally. And
if we learn this thing culturally, it stands to
reason that perhaps the ways in which we transmit these
skills, we could apply these skills and make other
species have these skills too that we can find soft
means to install again, broad brush, install in
their brains, completely new skills, new abilities,
including new abilities to culturally learn. Uh And indeed
, it seems to be, you know, this
does not mean that this whole approach of the CD
A is is completely correct. Although these days,
I tend to believe that maybe it is right,
but it certainly is in favor of this approach that
we see that if we train, if we put
our minds to it, if we put our intentions
behind it, if we apply everything that we can
to make apes copy, nohow, we succeeded.
We can, we can make them different apes,
we can change them, we can cognitively change them
. We install something new in their brains that they
wouldn't otherwise have. That's the other implication. And
that is what happens intentionally or not. You know
, it depends on the study uh when we incarcerate
apes. Now, that means then because no ape
is running around in the wild and no human is
running around in the wild, inculturated apes. And
this is not the case now and this hasn't been
the case in any time in the evolutionary past of
apes that we need to exclude. This is just
very, very simple logic. We need to exclude
this incarcerated apes um from our equation. They cannot
provide the answer. They are interesting if you want
to study the whole approach of C VA and so
on. They're very interesting, you know, for
these other reasons. But if we want to understand
what, why apes have and what, you know
, how they make their cultures and by implication,
what our last common answer that uh we must fully
exclude uh incarcerated apes. That's why I whenever I
absolutely can. I try not to study incarcerated apes
. You know, the only time when we do
is if they are intermixed with un incarcerated apes and
then we hope that the un incarcerated apes come first
and test first. You know, then it's interpretable
. If the incarcerated apes do it first, then
it's uninterpretable. Ok. So, uh I mean
, I wasn't planning on asking you about this,
but since you mentioned Cecilia Hayes there, I've had
an interview with her in 2019. And so I
, I can't really avoid asking you this now.
So uh I would like to ask you more about
what do you think about her approach to culture?
I mean, to what extent, but at this
point in time, would you agree or disagree with
her proposals and her claims? And if she,
if she was correct, what do you think would
be the implications in terms of how we approach culture
from an evolutionary sl slash phylogenetic perspective? Because I
mean, wouldn't that change the game uh to some
extent because there, there, there are people.
Uh I, I mean, and I'm not saying
they are wrong but uh when it comes to how
culture evolved, uh they tend to think about particular
uh cognitive mechanisms as having to be set in place
in a particular species for it to be able to
either uh have culture entirely or not, or to
be able to have specific kinds of culture or cultural
manifestations like language, for example, right? Uh
But I, but I mean, I, if
she was correct, wouldn't that have a big impact
on how we think about culture, particularly from a
biological perspective? Several people in the past, I
had proposed that this whole idea of having all these
modules in the brain uh being evolved separately and so
on, it, it doesn't really work because we
don't have, this is actually an argument made by
Mike to Marcelo in his 99 book, The Cultural
Origins of Human Cognition. So Mike went a long
way in a similar direction as as Hayes, but
he actually stopped short only of uh for a few
stops, let's say, um he said his argument
was we don't have much time, uh evolutionarily speaking
, if we look at archaeology and so on uh
to explain the human condition. And so this is
just not very convincing that we would have enough time
to have all these modules installed in our brain.
There are the reasons why this was always a little
bit dubious and Hayes just, just, I mean
, she did a wonderful job, she went some
steps further and she said, OK, uh where
Mike said, we have some adaptations such as he
focused on imitation, a sub form of, of
know how copying fine uh general perfect direction. Um
uh Haman said, even that even that has a
cultural origin, right? Uh And, and in
her book, and in her B BS paper and
so on. She listed quite convincing data sets and
I'm sure you talked about that in the interview.
It's quite convincing the case that the cultural learning of
cultural learning is the thing in humans. But for
my own approach, just because this is important for
, for, for me here as well. For
my own approach, it doesn't really matter if there's
no how copy this super individual, know how copying
if we humans get the genetically broadly speaking or culturally
, as long as we have it, right?
So my approach is mute on where it came from
it. I'm not saying it doesn't matter, but
it's for all current purposes is mute on where it
came from. Um uh As long as it's there
and as long it is as it is uh meaningfully
link to all these phenomenon here. And I think
it is uh then um you know, that that
approach still works because in either case, I would
say in either case, you have this missing in
the, you don't really see the signature signal that
super individual know how copying would have led to in
wild a culture, right? And we don't see
super individual know how copying spontaneously either. So putting
it all together, you know, it doesn't matter
where we humans have it from what seems to be
a factor that apes don't have it at all or
they have it to such a low degree or so
or show it so rarely that it really doesn't translate
in special types of culture that would be similar to
the human spec type of culture that we have here
, right? Um I should also say that maybe
there are other species that can copy super individual,
know how you know in some domains, some people
talk about whale song copying, you know, in
a super individual area, there is there was some
debate around that too. But be that as it
may here, we are talking about the apes,
right? And they are the phylogenetic uh meaningful comparison
. And whenever we looked, uh we could not
find these kind of things in the apes. OK
. So um let me ask you now about uh
another kind of questions. So uh we've already mentioned
a few times during the interview uh social learning.
So and of course to study ape social learning,
people use different kinds of tasks. And the question
I would like to ask you is do you think
that the tasks that are commonly used to study ape
, social learning are suitable? Yes. Yeah,
I mean suitable for what? Right. I have
to be quite blunt here. Um My blunt reaction
would be to say they are claimed to be suitable
for certain purposes, the kind of purposes that we
talk about today in this interview. And I think
for that purpose, they prove to be unsuitable.
Um Let me, let me explain a little bit
. The main task that is being used. Um
The main task that is being used is the so
called um, two target task. It's essentially a
task you can imagine. Uh if, if we
have a box here and this is a box here
and then there is a, there is a door
and the door can be pulled open, it can
be pushed over, right. So you push it
, you get the food inside, you pull it
, you get the and then one group of Apes
sees the the pushing, you know, another group
of Apes sees the pulling and then people say,
uh oh, and the result is frequently, not
always, but frequently. Yes. The ones that
saw the pushing, they, they do the pushing
and the ones that saw the pulling, they do
the pulling good. And but, but then on
this level, there is no disagreement. I've done
these tasks myself. And, you know, sometimes
I find I found this too. So the phenomenon
is not a question, the interpretation and the interpretation
is that some people, first of all, they
then claimed we are looking at action, copy,
at the behavior copy. But that can't be true
because for example, here, you know, I
can make it so that you don't even see my
actions and these things move. In fact, that
was a point that Celia Hayes made in, I
think in the nineties. But apart even from that
, apart, even from that, there is a
bigger problem here. The bigger problem is that people
then thought doing these tasks. Um we find special
types of learning, special types of learning that we
only find in the human case. And that explain
all of the human culture here. Now, that's
a huge problem because it turns out that not just
humans and not just apes copy in these tasks,
dogs copy in these tasks. OK? Then you
might say dogs are domesticated and so on, you
know, but recently, uh also reptiles copy in
these tasks, right? So if you want to
take this task performance and these two target tasks as
a special way of learning, you have got a
problem because then you would expect reptiles. I have
nothing against reptiles, you know, but you don't
just see it, you, you don't see it
, then you would expect reptiles to have humanlike culture
too. That really is the key. That is
the first hint that, you know, we have
been barking up the wrong tree with these tasks.
I can say that because I've done these tasks myself
, right? So I think it's, it's fair
if I, if I say this done this task
myself and I think we, we have, we
have been doing the wrong thing there. The other
big big clue is the empirical finding that if you
look whether the apes, in this case, the
apes, if they can pull the door open on
their own without having seen it pulled open or if
they can push the door open without having seen the
door being pushed open, not just the door of
the board removal, leber movements. You know,
there are different versions of these cars. In all
cases. We've done a review on that together with
Lydia Hopper and Carl Von SYK. Um, we've
done a review and we found, well, actually
, uh as you might imagine because they don't sound
very difficult these tasks, actually, the apes can
just solve these tasks in all of these ways on
their own. This is of importance for the current
interview as well because as I said earlier, we
what we need to find is know how copying that
is the copying of, know how that is super
individual. So we are back to the same kind
of um learning in these cases that we already talked
about when we talked about the orangutan not cracking.
If you can potentially develop this, know how on
your own. Anyway, then all you need is
know how triggering you need triggering of know how that
is latently already there. That's very different from copying
, know how that you could not produce on your
own. So for this reason, these two target
tasks and there are many, many of them and
so on, you know, for this purpose,
they, they just don't work, they work for
other purposes. Uh People are very interested in so-called
social learning biases and so on this is like the
traffic lights for, for social learning under which circumstance
to your social learning. That's fine. Absolutely.
You can use these tasks for that. You know
, there is very nice uh papers by Rachel Candle
and others and so on. Very nice. You
can do that. But for the current purpose,
you know, human like culture and so on,
um it turned out empirically, you cannot, you
know, uh you can design maybe better tasks uh
that, that, you know, the the animals
cannot solve on their own. Um But you would
have to make sure in these tasks that they are
about, know how not about no, where,
no, what and so on. So again,
as always, the devil is in the detail.
I told you at the very beginning, culture is
a slippery concept and it becomes even more slippery when
you make these distinctions. But I would argue we
have to make these distinctions otherwise we don't get it
, you know, the distinctions between human and ape
culture. And so what would be in your opinion
, suitable tasks to studying ape social learning? Yes
. So this task exists. Um The first was
done by uh by a consortium of, of researchers
. Um Michael Marcelo was there, Joseph Cole was
there as well. And what they did is they
essentially they um made some chimpanzees learn new begging gestures
. Mhm Translated into this interview in, in uh
one would say they taught, they taught, they
trained them, they trained them, you know,
this is not to be confused with copying these,
these animals didn't copy Mike and just happen. And
the others, you know, they train these animals
to show, you know how to beg from humans
, know how good. And uh and then uh
I think 18 observer chimpanzees saw this new, know
how be being used as a begging gesture, you
know, and what happened is uh these uh these
observers saw it and every time this uh train chimpanzees
would use this new begging gesture, they would get
food. It was a perfect begging gesture, you
know, from the perspective of these observers. Now
, did any of these observers copy this new know-how
, including I think one son of one of the
demonstrators, you know, so it's, it's exactly
this mother uh kid relationship that we always see uh
in these wild shows, you know, no,
not a single one of them copied uh any of
these know hows, right? So these, these
are suitable, you make them ideally, you make
it so that you've got a large baseline. You
, you check really if they show any of this
uh no how on their own spontaneously. And then
if they don't, you train them to show that
and you show this to others. And I myself
have because I always thought this is exactly the kind
of study that we need. This is the gold
standard study. So my group uh we have done
a couple of these studies and overall, I think
we have now tested, I, I wanna say
over 100 apes different species, you know, all
general actually. And um in no cases, in
no cases, did we find any time any super
individual know I copy? This is very strong evidence
that our hypotheses that we held uh was always correct
. Right. Um Or let me, let me
, let me put it so that it's easier digestible
. Maybe for, for those still skeptical, given
that we tested, I think over 100 chimpanzees uh
oh no, over 100 apes of different general and
that none of them ever copied super individual know how
in a technical domain in a non-technical domain uh from
, from aid demonstrators from human demonstrators and majority conditions
. So several showed them, you know, uh
in all kinds of ways. And given that we
never found any super individual know our copying, not
it, it supports the view that if apes have
supervision or copy they applied either super rarely, right
? Or are very weakly. This is of high
importance because all the cultural evolution models show that you
need a certain threshold level of both the frequency,
the reliability of the social learning and the strength of
this social learning. So said in this way,
even if they sometimes very rarely do this, it
just wouldn't be enough to have them have this kind
of human culture that we humans have right. So
that is, that is, I think a strong
statement that we can make with the data that we
have at hand right now. OK. And so
what can we tell from those data then? Because
I would imagine that uh one claim that someone could
make, could make is something like, OK.
So then does this all mean that uh apes do
not socially learn and they do not and cannot have
culture? I mean, I is that a plausible
claim to make it is not a plausible claim?
I have said extremely explicitly. I think in the
last uh paper uh I said apes, I think
I quote myself correctly here. Apes have culture and
nobody denies this. I could not say it more
strongly, right? Apes have culture. Nobody denies
this. Nobody I know denies this. But what
we need is a pluralistic approach to culture. Not
all cultures are created equal, right? And so
apes have many different types of culture. They have
very, we know this securely. They have cultures
of know what to eat. Maybe they would even
starve if they wouldn't have this culture, know what
to eat. It's very strong in that they learn
socially what to eat, you know, from those
around them, from their mothers and so on.
That's a, that's a culture, but it's a
different culture, but they clearly have it. They
also have got to know where cultures, where to
be, you know, and they also quite surely
know their territory and so on, you know,
so they socially learn that too. So they've got
all kinds of cultures, but when it comes to
know how their culture is basically uh uh about no
le and know how that they trigger. In each
case. Uh I use this term, by the
way from Dan Sperber, he made this very useful
distinction between the stuff that is already kind of there
and just needs triggering and the stuff that really needs
copying. And um Andrew Bask and I, we
have recently worked on that to lay more detail in
, in that it's a, it's a paper and
press, I think you recently interviewed Andrew as well
. So um so that that difference is very,
very important when it comes to know how the know
how is triggered but not copied in the sense that
we have been talking about this year. But in
order in order to have all of these things and
language, you know, and many other subdomains of
human culture, we need know how copy and without
it, we we, we cannot get that.
So um I would even say it like this apes
have many types of culture, but they do not
seem to share in this special type of culture that
we humans have and maybe other species have maybe whales
and all right. But I would also say that
this also doesn't mean that humans have all types of
possible culture that is also not the case bats,
for example, they communicate in ranges that we can't
communicate in. So, you know, we wouldn't
have this kind of uh culture if, if the
bats have special types culture based on that, right
? So you need to always look what kind of
cultures do these species show. And we see that
there is a difference in the kinds of cultures that
apes and humans show just like there was a difference
between uh different other kinds of animals in the cultures
that they show. OK. So with all of
that in mind, I have one last question then
. So we've talked about uh differences or potential differences
and similarities between ape culture and human culture. A
a different kind of question and related one is where
do those differences come from? Yes. Uh Well
, Ricardo, uh this is the million dollar question
and um and I don't think we have a very
good answer to that yet, you know. So
I think there is some good answers maybe more convincing
uh to some than to others, to all the
other questions that you had. Um But for this
one, we are quite in the dark yet.
I have argued and I might have used the same
argument in the last interview that we did. Um
I have argued in the past that in order to
try to shed light on this particular question, why
we got the way that we got? And so
on, we should first answer the question. When
did we go the way that we got first?
And if we have a good understanding of when we
became like that, then uh we can look at
the circumstances that acted at the time and at the
time, directly preceding it. And that is ultimately
the reason why even though I was a psychologist and
a biologist before, um that now I still maintain
these directions, but that I'm now an archaeologist.
So now I'm I'm trying to understand this when this
is my, my current quest as great. So
, Doctor 10, uh as I said at the
beginning, I'm also leaving a link in the description
box to our first interview. Uh Would you like
to mention again where people can find you and your
work on the internet? So uh if you Google
my name or it will, the things that pop
up will be the Google scholar account. Of course
, my, my website would be probably uh currently
the best place. It's a, it's a Google
site as well and, and easy to find.
Thank you so much. OK. Thank you so
much again for coming on the show. It's been
a real pleasure to talk to you. Thank you
so much. Thanks. Maybe that is the third
time. Let's see. Thanks. Hi guys.
Thank you for watching this interview until the end.
If you liked it, please do not forget to
like it, share comment and subscribe. And if
you like more generally, what I'm doing, please
consider support the show on Patreon or paypal. You
have all of the links in the description of this
interview. This show is brought to you by En
Lights learning and development done differently. Check their website
at alights dot com. I would also like to
give a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters per Larson, Jerry Mueller and Frederick Sunda
Bernards O of Election and Wiser Adam Castle Matthew Whitting
Whitting Bear. No wolf, Tim Hollis, Eric
, Alania John Connors, Philip Forrest Connelly, Robert
Winde Ruin. Nai Z Mark Nevs Colin Holbrook,
Simon Columbus, Phil, Governor Michael Stormer Samuel Andreev
for the S Alexander Dan Bauer Fergal, Ken Hall
, Herzog Michel, Jonathan Libra Jars and the Samuel
K, Eric Heins, Mark Smith, Jan We
Amal S Franz David Sloan Wilson, Yasa, Desu
Roma Roach. Diego, New Jannik Punter Mani Charlotte
Bliss, Nicole Barbar W and P A Guy Madison
Gary G Haman. Some of the Adrian Yin Nick
Golden Paul talent in Ju Bar was Julian Price Edward
Hall, Eden Bronner, Douglas Fry Franca Bertolotti,
Gabriel Pan Cortez, Lelis Scott Zachary Fish, Tim
Duffy, Sonny Smith, John Wiesman, Martin Aland
Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul George Arnold Luke
Loak Georges, the Often Chris Williamson, Peter Oren
David Williams, the Costa Anton Erickson Charles M Alex
Shaw and M Martinez Chevalier, Bangalore atheists Larry Daley
Junior, Holt Eric B. Starry Michael Bailey.
Then Sperber Robert. Grassy Rough. The RP MD
. Ior Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radix,
Mark Campbell, Richard Bowen Thomas, the Dauber Luke
Ni and Chris story, Manuel Oliveira, Kimberly Johnson
and Benjamin Gilbert. A special thanks to my producers
is our web gem Frank Luca, Tom Weam Bernard
Yugi Ortiz Dixon Benedict Mueller Vege, Gli Thomas Trumble
, Catherine and Patrick Tobin. John Carlo Montenegro,
Robert Lewis and Al Nick Ortiz. And to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Serge Adrian and Bogdan
Kenny. Thank you for all.